voilà donc on se retrouve en plateau
avec de nouveaux invités qui se sont
installés pour parler donc littérature
sur le plateau nous ont rejoints gérald
bloncourt bonsoir vous êtes poète
peintre photographe haïtien exilé en
france depuis 1946 jacques fournier
bonsoir l'ancien directeur de la maison
de la poésie à aiguille en cours est
également geneviève morel professeur au
lycée emilie de breteuil à montigny le
bretonneux vous étiez mobilisés dans le
cadre de cette journée consacrée aux
écrivains persécutés
alors on va parler de cette mobilisation
on va aussi évoquer la question du
goncourt des lycéens c'était aujourd'hui
la remise du prix du goncourt des
lycéens une fois de plus les jeunes
n'ont pas suivi leurs aînés ils ont mais
non pas récompensé jérôme ferrari mais
joël dycker pour la vérité sur la
ferrari qui héberge aimerait juste le
point de vue de nos invités sur ce
goncourt des lycéens est ce que c'est un
bon prix déjà j'aimais lui fait voler
l'idée du goncourt est très intéressant
du goncourt des lycéens est très
intéressante et je trouve que
appartiennent au monde des jeunes lisent
on peut être que satisfait nous on
organise le prix poésie vie des
collégiens on collabore au prix
littéraire régionale
voilà on est on est on est très heureux
quoi vous en pensez quoi
lorsqu on voit qu'ils aiment et pour
tous qui permet d'accéder aux livres et
je me rappelle quand même si on était
tous trois fait on exige tout on avait
lieu un breton de du coup reçu à la fin
on était au courant de ces choses là et
je pense que c'est important
voilà je rappelle en ce qui concerne ce
goncourt des lycéens que deux mille
élèves ont désigné le lauréat dans une
cinquantaine de classes en france dont
ceux du lycée jean vilar de plaisir une
section de première littéraire à
bouquiner la sélection officielle avant
de donner son verdict l'une des élèves
était d'ailleurs présente à rennes pour
les dernières délibérations aujourd'hui
avant de rejoindre ses camarades et son
enseignante à paris où ils sont reçus
d'ailleurs en ce moment au ministère de
l'éducation nationale le goncourt des
lycéens qui fête ses 25 ans un quart de
siècle journée internationale des
écrivains persécutés emprisonnés en ce
15 novembre une journée qui existe
depuis 1980 et c'est donc notre fait du
jour